is there a point to even telling dirty
jokes like sometimes i think telling
jokes about uh did it just get brighter
in here is that is that literally just
your aura
we are all luminous stardust beings with
self-awareness so you just have to turn
it on
follow-up to that
how
it's called the lightness of being
okay the lightness of being
so how it means
you don't do anything you're just being
well i've heard you say things like that
before that you're here
but you're not really here isn't that
yes this is my body that's here
i'm i never left home
where is that
outside of space and time
how's that going
it's it's the matrix it's the grid well
that's what i'm that's what i'm getting
at so you're separating yourself from
this persistent illusion that we call
reality yeah this is a socially induced
hallucination yes that insists right
it's loud
it's colorful melodramatic it's
melodramatic tells dirty jokes tells
dirty jokes yeah it's this
right yeah i would say though that you
know
it's an insane asylum yes sir and we're
all in it but the choice is
you can be an inmate or you can pick up
your visitors badge
and then once i pick up the visitor's
badge i can leave
no then you can enjoy the show without
getting sucked into the melodrama
so we're all just kind of waiting for a
metaphysical chief to smother us with a
pillow throw the water thing
i'm just trying to put these in lay
terms
a cuckoo's nest reference getting a
spattering of applause in 2013. who
would have thought
who would have thought i want to put
this to you
i actually think what you and i do and
having a talk show in particular is is a
cosmic dance between a quest for
permanence meaning i want this recorded
and collected and also an embracing of
impermanence because every day we do a
new show so i don't even remember what
we did yesterday does that resonate with
you it does if you live in the moment
then the past is gone it's not here
and the future is not yet now is the
moment otherwise you're living in a
waking dream if you're always thinking
of the past and the future you're not
actually alive you're living in a dream
well your your ego wants to keep you in
the past or the future otherwise it
ceases to exist
the ego is another illusion anyway
and fighting the ego with the ego is the
ultimate melodrama of the ego
god i have so many things i wanted to
ask you but i just blanked on what i was
about to say that's the key blank out
yield
when you blank out you tune in
take that tv critics
when i'm blanking i'm doing a good job
i'm doing a very good job